good morning Millennials and welcome
back to the toast happy Tuesday and I'm
so excited to be back in studio we've
got audio and video going today because
in lieu of Jax and there's nobody like
Jax I'm not you know gonna beat around
the bush there's not it's true there's a
really close second and I have to say it
brings me so much joy I love podcasting
with you it's so easy it's everything
and the audience loves you too like I
have people who I love who I ask them to
come on and The Toasters don't Jive and
it like sucks because I love them but
I'm like sorry you're not coming back
you are always requested and it makes me
so happy because you make my job so
[__] easy oh my God that is so nice I
know it's true first of all Jackie is
everything of the sort incomparable to
even get to be like even a distant
second is such an honor and a privilege
and I'm so excited to have you here
because like you're doing the most you
know you have a lot to update the
toasters on your own tour yes yes I am
I'm on tour and I'm hating it I know
because we don't get to see each other
like it's the summer you're like one of
the three people like to hang out with
and you're gone every weekend I know and
I'm just gonna have to call stassi up
and tell her to stop well luckily she's
having a baby I know so she can't like
extend the tour so her third trimester
so we are we only have like six shows
left we have not this weekend we're off
this weekend but the following we have
Port Chester because I know we have
obviously a lot of Tri-State girls
um Port Chester Huntington the best
theater and then it's in New Jersey I
really should know right now Red Banks
yeah Red Bank Red Bank I think it's a
singular Bank okay Red Bank New Jersey
The Count Basie Theater is it nice
um it is except
um the last and I had an amazing show
the last time I was there but something
actually scary happened to me I told you
this story sometimes they're haunted no
it's not haunted you've been spending
too much time with stocking
um it's
I went in the summer and I had like such
a busy day I did the toast we drove and
I just like had forgotten to eat which
is like not something I'm really like
that happens to me a lot this happened
there and I get on stage and I towards
the end of the show I started getting
really dizzy and hot and I'm like I'm
you know trying to be funny I'm like am
I gonna faint like I really thought I
was gonna faint I actually wrapped the
show like 10 minutes early I didn't do
this like final segment because I was
like on the verge of fainting and I was
like what's going on and then Ben was
like are you okay I'm like no and then I
realized I hadn't eaten I'm just like so
skinny like oh my God and it was like
one of the scary the theater is fine it
wasn't the theater's fault it was just
one of the scariest moments of my life
that's crazy did you see the video of
Heather McDonald fainting on stage no
recently yeah like no not recently like
maybe a year or two years ago no she
painted on stage and she actually
fractured her skull because like the
back of her head hit the floor and she
came on the toast after and told the
whole story and what happened she don't
she doesn't know she just like collapsed
I've actually I don't want to jinx
myself because I also got really like
lightheaded today on the way in so I had
my like Road oats when I walked in but
um I'm not a fainter I've never fainted
by the way neither have I knock on wood
I came really close in a hot tub once I
was in a hot tub for like too long mine
no not yours not yours it was like uh
when we were on vacation and should we
tell everyone we should tell everyone
Taylor um invented me over to her home
which was so lovely we had such a great
night on Memorial Day weekend yes and we
have like a blow it's not like a real
hot tub it's like inflatable and it was
really enjoyable it was so warm and
before we got in you were like this just
please don't pee in it because it's so
little right it's literally in like it
is just um a kid's swimming pool yeah
it's like an inflatable kid swimming
pool with like a heater in it and I said
I would never that's disgusting and the
thing when you said I would never I
thought fraudulent and a liar because I
would always I mean if I'm in your pool
I'm peeing if I'm in your real hot tub
I'm peeing I agree I'm coming in your
shower a thousand percent if I'm in your
bathtub I'm eating so I said I would
never thank you so much for inviting me
over and my and you invited Ben and my
friend Abe like you were such a gracious
host I said I would never but we had
been drinking yes but that's why like
this is the thing is I'm not usually
like that like I'm not like a judgey ew
germy freaky person you can be it's like
gross it's just you have to drain it and
then [__] clean it and then it's like
it's just such a process so I told her
that I didn't and then probably an hour
later I had drank a little bit more and
I told everyone that I did in fact pee
in the hot tub three times so three
that's like a half of the water content
okay now that we're like you know being
honest how many times it was three I
wasn't lying about the amount of times
but somebody else peed in it too I won't
say who it is it was Abe I know
spring and I thought to myself I was
like pouring drinks and I was like
they're either talking [__] yeah or
they're [__] peeing and then when we
left it was like thank you so much for
not like dragging me into it too because
he knew like I knew that he peed when I
told everyone that I peed three times I
also knew that apid and he was like
thank you so much because he like wants
to be invited back you know so guess
what so I went into the next day and I
was like [__] it like just like throw
the chemicals in and let's just see and
so I was in it it tastes like you've
been there for a while did you pay she
was like did you feed and I did okay
what there's me that's not fair we got a
huge fight so what he wanted to say to
me is thank you for opening the door no
because never again but Tay was like I
can't believe you Pete I was like you're
gonna yell at me and I flipped because
like that's the thing in our
relationship is everybody she treats
everybody was like no big deal because
she's a gracious host but then me me I'm
out to a completely different standard
no that's uh that's me and Ben no uh for
Ben it's like do as I say not as I do so
we got in like a little GIF and I was
like if you're gonna yell
no and if you guys yelled at me I would
have been like no you're 100 right like
I shouldn't have done that I promised
that I wouldn't I was a guest in your
home you were gracious enough enough to
invite your home and open your home up
to not only me not only my husband but
also my friend and I came and took a big
piss on it like literally you would have
been right to yell at me Taylor Donahue
can call me and yell at me if she wants
wow I've actually never seen you admit
to oh my God by the way one thing about
me like I'm never wrong but when I am I
admit it I feel like for us I feel like
it's actually like a decent quality of
mine like I know when I'm wrong yes I
think I'm I'm so self-aware I actually
become paranoid and unself-aware like
I'm actually taking responsibility for
things that I didn't even do yeah I will
apologize all day long you by the way
you were just where San Diego we were
just in San Diego and then we went to
Denver short trip but hellish travel
yeah I can't travel like it's this is
like the time of year where everyone's
traveling and the airlines like forgot
how to Airline so we were stuck in the
tarmac for like two and a half hours
leaving Newark to go to uh LA and they
were like we can't find a find an open
flight path what
and he's like oh we found one and then
he came back oh that's reassuring 30
seconds later and was like up it's gone
weather what is it I'm like this is like
I don't need to know how the sausage is
made yeah yeah just give me that get me
there but he said like welcome to flying
in the you know Northeast during the
summer I'm like that's not that's not a
thing that's not a thing it's beautiful
we can go everywhere locally what do you
mean no and it's like this summer well
we can go places in the winter but like
that doesn't even make any sense I know
I hated him um but I saw that you had
like a VIP guest come to your show I saw
Alex Cooper came to the San Diego show
and I have one two questions one how was
that and two
have other like people come to the show
and or like the show coming up in L.A I
mean I know I came so like obviously
that was a big deal yeah
um but first of all how was that
I was dying were you nervous wait so on
the flight out there low I was texting
with her because I was like you might
need to book me a flight tomorrow to San
Diego directly this is like [__]
crazy yeah so she was like you have to
make it to the show in San Diego and I
was like why don't you just like Alice
Cooper's coming I was like shut the [__]
up how did I make you more nervous
recently mad and they like really hit it
off yes it made me nervous but I was
also really excited because nobody's so
great like you have nothing to be
nervous about you I've seen your show
you are so funny like I can't recommend
seeing sausage show enough obviously
because it's great but like to see
Taylor in her element is such a joy
honestly you were amazing you're a
little bit biased because you're my
friend no I'm like a hater to my core
and I'm not this type of woman who like
lifts up other women you are not a woman
who supports one no not in the slightest
because I think that makes us weak like
honestly I agree if you stunk it up like
I would have seriously been telling you
you wouldn't have said anything like you
didn't say anything Ryan's 40th birthday
party I wouldn't say anything the night
of but like when we call when we like
recapped then it would have been like
what would you have said constructively
I would have said notes and my and my
only note was that you need to slow down
the way you this and that's that's
because that's one of my big biggest
challenges as well and it's actually I'm
scared of Silence because I have done
this for you know recently I was doing
the math I was so I hit 100K on
Instagram congratulations thank you and
um but I had to wait till 101 to even
mention it because the [__] haters
would have been like oh she reached 100
unfollow unfollow unfollow but um what
was my point oh I did the math it took
me 17 years to get to a hundred thousand
I would feel bad for you if you were out
here trying
the fact that you have a hundred
thousand people who follow you when you
give them nothing on Instagram is
a miracle you should have less so you
know what it didn't take you 17 years
it's not like you're out here pounding
the payment every day posting content
trying to do this doing giveaways this
is this shooting content outside your
house getting a photographer you
literally posted like from Brian's
birthday in Portugal like three weeks
later
it's sure so you're not even trying so
good for you honestly it's more
impressive
it is so but why did I bring that up it
took you 17 years and you're doing
stand-up now oh yeah whatever wow I'm
really slow today I'm so sorry if you're
gonna be like can you never ever back
again after tour um okay so Alex so I
was like I have to get out there I'm so
excited and Alex and Hannah burner are
close and so I just like I've been like
it's a matter of time before I meet Alex
actually I thought Alex was gonna come
to Hannah's bachelorette party last
spring but um she wasn't able to make it
so anyway but I was like this has to
happen so I was so excited but then I
got so nervous because having anybody
having you they're having Brian they're
having my wife there yeah like people
that I love and Trust I get nervous over
so somebody knew who I have no bearings
on whatsoever I just was like very
nervous but she was so she was actually
backstage I mean she was like she
couldn't sit down the audience like
ahead of time yeah you guys got mobbed
when you came in I lived for every
moment of it we have learned our lesson
though now it's like when we have high
profile guests coming we just have them
like come backstage and just slip out
right before
so um so she did that so she was
backstage we got to meet her before the
show which is again it's interesting
because like pre-show meets and post
show meets very different Vibes yeah
what do you have to say about them when
I do a show if anybody I know like Ben's
parents come to a lot of shows and I ask
that they just show up and not tell me
and then they come back afterwards I'm
like oh you guys were here exactly if
they bring their friends like that it's
not even like like high profile people
who make me anxious it's like it's
really like people I know personally
like people who are at my wedding like
distant relatives like that like I just
want to die like it's it's so painful so
everybody knows there's like a big rule
like if anyone's coming to the show do
not tell Claudia just like get tickets
right for Ben or Margo or through the
agency and come back afterwards but
nobody's allowed to talk to me before
like I that's like I don't get nervous
people are always like I never get
nervous people that I know coming kills
me I'm with you what is that but if I if
somebody high profile is coming that
like [__] gases me up I'm like yeah
like I'm so being like I want to show
this [__] that I'm [__] great like
that gases me up so I will say that I
was nervous but like when I'm nervous I
tend to actually run the occasion yes
and so I was like really going going
over my side I was like really like
going over my points for when we do pop
culture hour because I knew I was gonna
do like Vanderpump whatever so she
actually made me like [__] up my game
but she was so [__] nice that's
amazing I expected to like her but I
didn't expect to be like as comfortable
with her as I was she's like really down
to earth humble girly girl she's like
[__] she's she's one of us yeah she's
amazing that's so nice to hear when like
people live up to the expectations
because for the most part everyone's the
worst I know right last night I went to
dinner with this kid I'm sure you don't
know him because you're like a grandma
not on Tick Tock his name is Jake Shane
octopus lover do you know him I'm so bad
now he's like the big thing on Tick Tock
right now and he's a toaster and we now
have the same agent and she was like
he's coming to New York you actually get
dinner and you know me like I dread
leaving the house I dread meeting new
people and honestly I was like I can't
wait to get home when I tell you like we
couldn't stop talking I was obsessed
with him like the success that he's
having like so deserving like don't
worry you're not being I'm so jealous of
him
I did talk about you did you I forget
how you came up oh I was trying to
convince him to do stand up because he
really like he has it you know that's
like my life's Mission so you want me to
hate this person right now to push
people beyond their you know beyond
their limitations and show them that
they can do stand up and I was like
you're like really making it less
special that you tell me that like you
just meet this Tick Tock by the way
you're like we talked about octopuses
and all of a sudden you're my finest
work you're my protege like I'm like
look at her now
[Laughter]
thank you so much and it was a good
conversation don't make it nasty don't
make me nasty [__] I'm sorry I'm just
competitive yeah me too by the way like
like you spending all this time with
Saucy like it's really hard for me it's
been really hard for me I get it yeah so
octopus Lover's my new best friend [__]
I had dinner with him just to hurt you
wait wait a second what's up with the
octopus okay so let us know he loves
octopus and he started his account by
like rating like fancy octopuses all
over la like like dishes yeah yeah yeah
I'm dead and then his like his fan base
became like the [__] it's really
funny of course and now he does these
videos [__] PSA [__] PSA and he like
says something moronic it's very funny
he's really creative and different I
love him and he's like this 23 year old
gay kid I like we just literally talked
about like Joan Rivers we like it was so
like it was so nice to meet someone else
like rub it in but like we look really
connected
foreign
no and it's pride month and like the
gays are flocking to me and not to make
pride month about me oh my God but I'm
kind of like the number one Ally in the
world you know not to make pride month
about me yeah actually you peed into gay
person's hot tub so obviously that was a
hate crime that was an extremely gay
thing for me too actually
I was role-playing as a gay person
you're welcome love is love love wins
[Music]
pride month is really hard for me
because oh my gosh it's not about me you
know yeah how does that feel hard I'm so
sorry it's like the least you could do
is just kind of lift me up you know what
the straight struggle is so real that's
what I'm saying and as a Middle East
where's my month as a middle-aged
middle-aged what did I just say I'm
quite well I thought you were calling me
middle age on my [__] get out of here
no I would never talk about you or your
family or your dog's age ever again good
God she changed your lesson from last
time being on the toast
I always say that like I had a joke in
my set that was that I am a white
middle-aged man yeah straight man like
that is I like I relate so much to that
demographic and I just want to say like
it's really hard being us
I definitely feel and this is like the
most like performative white woman thing
to say I really feel like a gay man
stuck in a woman's body like I really do
and that's just kind of my Crosshair
that's why that's why pride is so hard
for me yeah how are you feeling about
like all these Brands dropping the
rainbow flag I mean as a gay man yes
it's hurtful
as a white woman do I care
I will say that for years the gay
community self-included we've mocked
these big Brands they call it pink
washing right yeah where it's like oh
now all of a sudden like you believe in
allyship and like you're gonna speak
about it because like you're going to
financially benefit off of like it's so
performative like it is yeah but now
that it's gone you miss it hurts it
really hurts don't it always seem to go
that [__] don't know what You Got Till
It's Gone you pay Paradise and put up a
pride flag
I wasn't ready for it one thing about me
like I'm gonna make pride month about
myself and I'm done I'm breaking and I'm
gonna bring it break into song which
like I said truly makes me a gay man how
that's that very accurate how uh by the
way is this singing going on the show I
know that there has been some
controversy over it yeah if you read our
podcast reviews which I genuinely don't
encourage anyone to do no uh um you know
Sarah Yelp you know Spotify has a new
thing what where you can't leave a
review on a podcast that they don't have
data of you actually listening to that
is incredible because I imagine a lot of
my negative reviews the positive ones of
course people that listen when you when
you like something you don't like go sit
and write about it you go enjoy it like
exactly yeah I think that's actually a
really smart new thing that it's not
even that new but relatively new thing
that Spotify does but I do always say at
the end of taste of Taylor every week
like please go rate review And subscribe
because it's like if you went to a
restaurant and didn't tip your waitress
yeah kind of like if you just like give
like an HGH hey girl hey no big deal
this content is free so the least you
could do is leave a review and a good
one yeah we're not encouraging bad if
you go and uh if you do one thing after
this episode it's take down your pride
flag and go leave a positive review
Thanks
um okay we've Dilly dallied literally so
long we have to get into the story and
we actually have amazing stories today
that I'm excited to get your take on am
I allowed to drink my matcha you are oh
Taylor's become so toxic like she drinks
matcha now and she ate like rolled oats
before she got here and I really need
you to stop
I'm sorry okay I'm ready for the past
five stories that you need to know
today's episode is brought to you by
Sephora specifically some of the
fabulous clean Beauty Brands available
at Sephora so whether you're really into
clean beauty or you just happen to love
great makeup this sponsor is for you for
me there are so many amazing brands that
I purchase at Sephora that I didn't even
know were clean and I know Jackie really
seeks out clean beauty products because
she's very much in her clean girl era
she's pregnant she's being really
conscious about what she puts in her
body and it's also just really
highlighted for me like we need to be
more conscious about what we're putting
on our face so so many brands that I
love that I've now learned are clean I'm
so happy about are available at Sephora
one of my favorite Brands is Merit
Beauty their cream blushes are amazing
their concealer is amazing house Labs is
also one of my favorite
um Brands it's available at Sephora and
it's Lady Gaga's brand and it is a clean
brand so I love their powder blush their
Foundation went so viral on Tick Tock
also another brand is West minnetellier
I've really been getting into them and
they're one of Sephora's clean Beauty
Brands they're contour and and bronzing
sticks are amazing clean beauty is
fabulous it's so important to learn what
ingredients are in our makeup and what
we're actually putting into our skin on
our lips you know these are our faces
ladies we've got to be really conscious
of what we're putting in there so
Sephora has amazing Brands everybody
knows that and a lot their clean Beauty
Brands are amazing you don't have to
give up quality for the clean Beauty
they're so good they work so well if you
want to learn more about clean Beauty
about clean Beauty Brands available at
Sephora go to sephora.com clean look
gorgeous and feel good today's episode
is also brought to you by Legacy box so
Lexi box is that sponsor that
everybody's always like Claudia what was
that Legacy box and you know what's so
funny we were having this conversation
yesterday because we did a legacy box
Legacy box is the best way to digitize
old Home Videos home phone home photos
camcorder VHS things like that and we
were watching some of the things we had
digitized yesterday and we realized we
have a whole other box in our basement
of camcorder footage that we've never
been able to get so we're doing another
Legacy box which is really exciting it's
the coolest it's the best it is the most
proficient way to digitize your old
memories bring those memories into the
modern world and it's also a great gift
you know Father's Day is coming up and
that's like kind of a really sentimental
beautiful gift and if there's just
favorite childhood memories of yours
like for us singing the Spice Girls in
our parents bedrooms like we never would
have been able to relive that if it
weren't for legacy box it's so easy you
load Legacy box up with your old tapes
film pictures and they'll send it back
to you completely digitized you'll get
it on a thumb drive or the cloud it's
ready to watch and easy to share it's so
simple it's basically like magic
I literally this was one of the easiest
things I've ever done they update you
with emails throughout the process being
like oh here's the tracking oh here it
was delivered here's what we're up to
now you feel like your memories are
really being protected and safeguarded
by Legacy bucks because they understand
how important like what they're holding
is it's literally your entire family's
Legacy in a box so of course we have a
great discount for you guys and with
Father's Day coming up I feel like this
is a really good gift don't let the
summer heat Aid your videotapes your
film reels and fade your memories visit
legacybox.com toast to shop their nine
dollar tape sale so that's legacybox.com
toast to unlock this incredible offer
great our first story is some breakup
news uh Taylor Swift and Matty Healy
have confirmed their breakup after just
one month of dating allegedly so Taylor
Swift and Matty Healy have broken up
after a world when romance page six has
confirmed a friend close to the
situation told teams either Taylor is
single again but the reason for their
split is unknown however A source told
Entertainment Tonight that's scheduling
and incompatibility were the cause is
they said Taylor and Maddie broke up
they're both extremely busy they realize
they're not compatible with each other
Taylor's friends want what's best for
her and they aren't shocked that their
relationship fizzled out since she
recently got out of a long-term
relationship right so I think that like
the internet had a lot to say about this
relationship and people are like
Taylor's listening to her fans no she's
not I feel like Taylor's the type of
person who like doesn't let her public
life dictate her private life because
that's such a toxic way to live like no
she keeps somebody on Twitter said this
like I'm gonna go do that like yes but
it was was a pouring outcry of like what
is she doing I know but there was also
pouring out Cry of Taylor being like
people being like yes Taylor like you
were in this serious ass relationship go
be with this rock star like go get
railed like who cares right and that's
true too it's like they could have just
been like [__] buddies and of course
it's like elevated because she is yeah I
am thrilled because I have become
through you I will give the credit where
credit's due I started to kind of like
get Taylor I will say actually my old
manager too he really like he was like
please watch the stadium special on
Netflix and I watched like the first
five minutes and I was like she's don't
get mad at me
this is an old man she's like trying to
dance like Beyonce and it's like making
me uncomfortable and like Taylor stop it
and so I said it's my manager and he's
like he was like please go back and
watch it you know he went back you know
who would never say something like that
octopus lover
he's the biggest 50 we actually had like
the best time last night talking about
Taylor Swift well I drink Macha now
because of stassi yeah I know and that's
why I did a relaxer
that's why
so if I didn't like stassi so much I'd
literally hate her I know I know I get
it she's just wonderful no right
um so I was like [__] this I'm not
watching it and then he's like please go
back and watch it again cut to me 20
minutes in hysterically crying and
screaming alone in my studio apartment
watching it so that was like what
beganeth the fandom and then just like
listening to songs with you and hearing
like perspectives and also like I've
been going down this Rabbit Hole of
watching how she handles herself on
stage during this tour like yelling at
the security guard
um fixing her garter forgetting the
words to songs relatable relatable Queen
so I'm obsessed with her and so I did
not like him for her okay because I just
felt like who do you see her with I
don't know actually I do know I mean I
don't know who but I know what gender
and it's a woman yeah I really I don't
I'm not outing her I want her to be gay
for the gay agenda I want her to be a
lesbian for our PR like we need it yeah
I mean it is pride month and you're like
over here speculating on another woman's
sexuality and that's not very Ally of
you I just said I would like it to be
I'm not outing there have been rumors
right see Taylor's being a toxic lesbian
but should we really be surprised no no
you're so toxic I learned it from you I
learned matcha from style scene I
learned toxicity from you and what will
get you farther in life matcha or Texas
today definitely being toxic a hundred
percent people respect toxicity
use so on Instagram I know you really
bring it on me thank you what a
compliment I'm trying to think who I
would like ship Taylor with
she's so and I hate this whole thing
it's like powerful women can date
whoever they want but like they really
can't like no they really really can't
oh you knew she should date who and I
know that you guys brought this up the
other day on the toast I saw a clip of
it and I agreed Taylor Kitsch
Taylor and Taylor yeah you love that
also I feel like his sexuality has been
questioned as well so they could be like
maybe very fluid together has his
sexuality been questioned very much so
very much so oh I would love a gay Tim
Riggins me too but I could just like
he's so hot but I also feel like he's
kind of
irrelevant so we could like follow her
around the world yeah that's the thing
it's like Maddie is the lead of like a
very successful band and they're super
International because he's based in the
UK right so like it's really not
feasible for her to be on a tour him to
be on a tour she really needs to date
someone who can like Jackie and I always
say like a businessman bow yeah who is
like worth billions but can work
remotely yes from her dressing room I
don't know again not to be like this but
just like I would see a lesbian
relationship too because I feel like two
women can be very successful and still
like share the Limelight whereas I think
it's hard for a man sometimes yeah that
is it is hard but it's also just not
feasible sometimes like with like
scheduling and yes I know I'm being
sexist though as well yeah the thing
about sexism it's kind of like an ism
I'm four same and I don't think men and
equal men and women should be treated
like the same yeah I think men should be
treated badly no like I want my dinners
paid for I want my drawers held for me
yes but I also want to be paid the same
so I'm just kind of toxic when it comes
to my my gender equality at least she's
on Brands I am on Brands um okay ready
for our next story yes this one is so
[__] funny okay so Pete Davidson is
like deeply unwell yeah he has left a
voicemail an extremely unhinged
voicemail for a woman who works at Peta
oh the animal rights organization I'm
already on board I'm obsessed Pete
Davidson is going to war with Peta over
the new dog that he bought and he fired
the latest shot via VIA a profanity
laced voicemail for the Animal Rights
group a move he says he doesn't regret
but he says it came from a place of
grief okay so Peter says that the actor
left a heated message for them for the
senior VP of Cruelty investigations her
name is daphna he got her name because
her name is what daphna is it daphna or
Daphne
d-a-p-h-n-a Dafna what do you think I
know how to [__] read you think I'm
illiterate yes [__] you don't even read
I have read 22 books this year what have
you done
what have you done misspelled every text
I send out daphna yes so he basically
got her name because she was the one who
issued a statement to TMZ she was
speaking on behalf of PETA did you see
that picture went viral of him and his
girlfriend buying a dog no but continue
it went viral because like they were
spotted together not because they were
buying a dog that nobody cared but so
that photo had went viral and then Peta
released a statement to TMZ just
basically expressing their
disappointment in Pete buying a puppy
instead of adopting from a shelter so he
saw that and got pissed and left a
voicemail for this woman daphna who was
the one who signed the statement to TMZ
Pete announces that he um he announces
himself he says hi it's Pete Davidson
and says he's responding to death in a
statement where he calls
um which he called uneducated and
premature he said he's allergic to dogs
as his rep told us and that's why he got
a Cavapoo which is a nearly
hypoallergenic dog breed because they
don't shed right he also says that the
dog is for his mother whose dog whose
dog died two weeks earlier so his mother
was grieving he went out and got a dog
and he got a dog that he could live with
you know he lives with his mother oh I
forgot Cavapoo is something that he's
not allergic to and there was like a
whole reason as to why he shopped not
adopted right he angrily tells daphna in
an explosive lace diatribe
to do her research but for talking to
the media drops an f-bond bomb and makes
a vulgar suggestion involving his penis
she told him to suck his dick oh amazing
Peta isn't backing down though of course
they're not because they're the worst so
T they told TMZ if Pete had done his
research he would know that there's no
such thing as a hypoallergenic dog but
at least a quarter of dogs in shelters
or purebreds and that Petfinder has
listings for homeless dogs of every
breed Under the Sun including the one
that he purchased TMZ contacted Pete
about his Furious voicemail and he
admits He was unaware he could adopt a
specific hypoallergenic dog he said he
was told it wasn't an option and if it
was it was super rare as for his anger
he addressed that by emphasizing his
family was really going through it after
his mother's dog died he said I haven't
seen my sister and my dog and my mom cry
like that in over 20 years I was trying
to cheer up my family I was already
upset that the store had filmed me
without my permission or acknowledgment
right then the organization Peta made a
public example of us making our grieving
situation even worse I am upset it was a
poor choice of words I shouldn't have
said what I said but I'm not sorry for
standing up for myself or my family team
Pete in this 100 also guess what will
happen if nobody goes to the stores
those dogs will end up at shelters no
it's a vicious cycle so technically you
know we you're wrestling every animal is
a rescue you're rescuing an animal from
a pet shop oh that's like some some
people singing yeah I'm not gonna get
into adopt on shop because like yeah you
should adopt but I didn't so moving on
um I kind of to me the most interesting
part of this story is the dog store the
picture got released because the dog
stores social media page put up a
picture of them that's [__] so it's
really [__] and like that's such a
breach of privacy and like not cool and
if he had asked if they had asked I'm
sure people would have been like sure
right picture of him and a dog going
viral no problem that like that sucks
and like this whole situation happened
because his privacy was breached you
know it's really interesting when it
comes to social media and like what's
appropriate what's not and in terms of
privacy like even I was with stassi's
daughter Hartford for a day before we
went on tour and I was taking a video of
her and I was like can I post this like
I always ask permission before you have
to you'll always have to ask permission
before you post anything yeah so with
kids especially it's but like and that's
my friend right I like even get like
Photo approval from you and my wife well
that's just because if you put up a
picture of me looking ugly you're on my
bad side you're dead to me there's a
simple explanation for that
but I just I mean they should have known
better no so like that sucks and
obviously Pete like is so funny that
like I feel like if anybody else had
done this like Alec Baldwin leaving a
voicemail for his daughter calling her a
thoughtless little pig we were all like
how disgusting but Pete Davidson like
telling this little randomly he just hug
his dick like sorry it's funny no it's
amazing and also Peter makes me want to
like stab bunnies I don't know why and I
like animals I want to be such a
visceral reaction to Peter I actually
like pita I really don't like pita tell
me more because I feel like they bully
people into doing what they think is
right immoral and it's like this is the
perfect example of it it's like listen
like I just feel like they're just too
aggressive in their pursuit of what they
want like I agree with like the actual
message that's interesting but I don't
even know what the message is because
they're so busy pissing me the messages
adopt don't shop
that's their only platform they're also
very anti-fur of course I'm talking
about in this particular issue yes their
whole message is like save the animals
don't eat milk sure [__] like that yeah
matcha
oat milk look at you Peta approved I
know Peter it's working see I actually
live a very Pita lifestyle oh my God
that's not true you have a meatloaf like
three times a week that was during the
pandemic and we were all doing things
that we regret yeah but we weren't
claiming to be Peter approved people
like you are right now give up today
yeah by the way you love fur I feel like
you have four fur coats fine I'm sorry I
have one I'm sorry didn't your wife get
you a fur coat for your birthday this
year
yes but it was
salvaged
and rescued you adopted it you didn't
chop it yeah it was rescued We rescued a
first scripted that was abandoned by an
old woman I'm assuming yeah who had
great taste and was wealthy right and
like it just would have been you know
gone to waste and that's not sustainable
living it's not actually not the
sustainable girly I personally I
actually don't wear fur
like you are so [__] lying right now
oh no by the way I don't wear fur you
give like fur collar Vibes no I don't
refer you give like for a risk nice
that's nice that that's Energy Zero I
don't refer you've never in your life no
I have in my life yeah I see you like
when you're like 13 with like a man
about Mitzvahs yeah sure jacket from a
big shrug on my way to like Obama
Twitter in the winter literally yeah no
for sure but I don't do that anymore
because I care about animals really yeah
well I can't afford it I'm
I can't afford the things that I want me
neither that's why we had to rescue
no literally This Woman's shop says like
that she's a fur rescuer I swear to God
whatever it is for Market yourself
honestly I I am constantly telling
myself like delusional things just to
get through the day so that's what this
woman needs to believe then I love that
Journey for her big delusional energy b
l no b-d-e yeah big delusional energy
yep you're probably the most delusional
person I know second to me but I think
I'm delusional like in the negative
sense like I don't delusion up I
delusion down that's actually so true
you have like very low self-worth and
you absolutely have to work on that I
know like you don't see what other
people see in you that is so nice thank
you and I think you do it as like a
means of like protecting yourself and
like deflecting yes but you're so I'm
like I feel like I'm always gas like
every time we're together I'm just
gassing you up I know my mom's always
like why do you have such low
self-esteem and I'm like I don't know
Mom um
like where do you think it starts and I
love her and she's my parents are so
wonderful but like definitely there was
some messaging given to me I know what
it was until it was be a good Catholic
girl and if you're not good and by good
they were like never drink never smoke a
cigarette never smoke pot like my mom
found a bowl in my car that fell in my
boyfriend's cargo short like a weird yes
like a weed bowl that's like that's high
school that was my reading in college
yeah and literally she woke me up in the
morning abusive and rude and she said I
found your crack pipe and I'm calling
the police not Babs with the drama I'm
so dramatic I found your crack pipe
crack pipe she's gonna find your ozone
pick and say I found your heroine middle
literally that was an A plus joke it was
amazing but yeah so I feel like I was
always like I was being so bad so like
yeah I forget that you grew up Catholic
Oh it really [__] me up didn't
yes really Catholic guilt is like a real
thing it's beyond a thing it's actually
a personality trait Jewish guilt is a
thing too but it's very different it's
like just a bit different it's about
like not seeing your family enough and
finishing all the in about like small
things yeah it's like finishing all the
food on your plate because our ancestors
and concentration camps have got one
bread roll every three days yes like
it's funny because like my parents
aren't critical but when they critique
it it's deep and what is it about if you
don't mind me asking like my entire
existence is a human right a career like
apartment yeah no like no it's no like
more like heaven hell like more like um
yeah they really like utilize the hell
[__] against you as a Catholic are your
parents still Catholic yeah my dad
actually converted he always wanted to
be Catholic which is like very toxic for
me
um Protestant which is like the same
[__] oh I didn't know you converted like
within the but back in the day he got uh
he had a communion or he got like um
baptized I don't [__] know uh when he
was like in his 50s or 60s wow yeah we
had to go to the worst mass ever it was
three hours long two of the hours in the
dark why I don't know when the woman was
farting in front of me honestly bless
her because she was the comedic humor
like The come comedic break I needed the
whole time oh man you are deeply unwell
and the more that I learned about you
like the more I understand why you're so
unwell you know does that make sense yes
it does today's episode is brought to
you by ZipRecruiter if you're listening
today we've got some advice for you stop
waiting and start using zip recruiter
they can help you find qualified
candidates for all of your roles fast
and right now you can try it for free at
ziprecruiter.com toast so ZipRecruiter
is so efficient at helping you hire and
here's how they use powerful matching
technology to quickly find and send you
the most qualified people for your roles
you can check out the people that zip
recruiter sends you and if you really
like one or two of them you can actually
personally invite them to apply with
just one click it makes them apply
sooner and you're more likely to find
someone that you like because you quite
literally selected them plus here's how
quickly ZipRecruiter can work to help
you hire four out of five employers who
post on ZipRecruiter get a quality
candidate within the first day if you're
a business owner you have people who
work for you you know how important it
is to find a quality candidate who you
get along with in a personality level
who has the skills that are required for
your role and hiring can be a really
treacherous Journey but not a zip
recruiter speed up your hiring process
with ZipRecruiter just go to this
exclusive link of ziprecruiter.com toast
to try ZipRecruiter for free only when
you go to ziprecruiter.com toast at
ziprecruiter.com
t-o-a-s-t this is one of the things that
you don't want to skimp out on like you
want the best quality candidates people
who are going to work for you who are
going to support you who are going to be
qualified who are going to be great and
it's just so easy to use that we've used
it for a million different roles like
video editors assistance in the past
like we have such success with
ZipRecruiter and I really can't stress
enough how fabulous it is and you can
get it for free when you go to
ziprecruiter.com
t-o-a-s-t zip recruiter the smartest way
to hire today's episode is also brought
to you by Squarespace so whether you
have a website you want to start a
website for e-commerce a Blog whatever
it is check out Squarespace it is the
go-to for all things websites they're
this but their Squarespace is the space
to sell anything they have the tools
that you need to get your business off
the ground including e-commerce
templates Inventory management a simple
checkout process and secure payments
whatever you sell Squarespace has
merchandising features to make your
products look their best online check
out squarespace.com toast for a free
trial and when you're ready to launch
use our offer code toast to save 10 off
your first purchase of a website or a
domain I have made many websites in my
life and I am not even remotely
qualified I'm not an engineer I'm not a
computer science girly and I can tell
you Squarespace is so easy their
templates are beautiful your website
will come out looking professional and
people will think you like hired a real
company to do it and you just use
Squarespace it's affordable it's
beautiful they have great little
features available to really make your
website work really well like you get
great analytics they have a one click
out of portability so you own all the
content that you put on your website
they help you find domains which can be
really hard to do and purchase them so
again our link is squarespace.com toast
for that free trial and once you're
ready to launch use the offer code toast
to save 10 off your first purchase of a
website or a domain squarespace.com
toast alright are you ready for our next
story which is like confusing the hell
out of me yes sunstrack says Kathy
Hilton did not film Real Housewives of
Beverly Hills Season 13 and that she was
missed now before I give the details I'm
so confused because it was my
understanding that Kathy Hilton gave
Bravo the ultimatum like it's either
Lisa Rena or me I'm not filming with
Lisa Rinna they fired Lisa Rinna so
Kathy won but then didn't even film
which is like a boss move isn't that so
Kathy though yeah to be like get rid of
this [__] ruin her life because it's
everything to rent out it's like this
much to Kathy yeah it's nothing she's
not even a full housewife she's a friend
of and then she's like oh you got rid of
Rena okay you know what I've changed my
mind kind of tired yeah I'm not gonna do
it so sunstrack was um interviewed by
someone and she said so they asked was
uh
like what's up with Kathy right was
Kathy missed on the show yes but is
there a void on the show because Kathy's
not there no there's still comical
moments it's still a great show but I
missed Kathy I'm sorry Kathy like will
be missed like some of the housewives
leave and the show is no worse or better
off like yes there will be a gaping hole
without Rina that's it's a toxic hole
and there will be a gaping hole without
Kathy and it's a comedic relief kind of
hole yes I mean who is hunky dory is my
favorite thing on the face of the planet
and it was kind of the the melodic way
in which she said it
hunky dory
was hunky dory
icon like imagine being so rich you
don't even know like colloquial terms
it's unbelievable like she's been so
rich for so long for so long that she
doesn't even know like the trendy uh
phrases and such you know I don't know I
feel like she will be missed but because
I know for a fact she chose to leave
like everyone's like oh I chose to leave
no you didn't there have been a few
people who chose to leave Bethany yes
Kathy Hilton yes
I feel like that's literally it me too
everyone else got like dragged out
always while their nails are like
scraping down the floor yep you had to
pull it from their cold dead hands so I
feel like there's a chance she could be
back so I won't be yeah sad but I also
think this is probably best for her
relationship with her sisters I was
gonna say if she continued on I think
part of her storyline this season would
be like the rift between her and and
Kyle that's why she's off actually
because she doesn't want to talk about
it and she knows they're going to make
them deal with it if she comes back yeah
and I think like the core of a lot of
the fights between Kyle and Kim and Kyle
and Kathy is that like the show is
Kyle's thing and it's hard for her right
like Kyle's been on the show for 10
years her sister came on for literally
three scenes in one season and was
automatically people's favorite
Housewife of all time and you know
Kyle's out here doing the most for eight
years and I think it was hard for her
honestly to sit back and like just watch
her sister be the bell of the ball
without having to do anything and Kyle
did set her own sister up I mean she she
pitted against her like all that [__]
Rena did was for Kyle you know Kyle not
do a good job of protecting her sister
and so I can imagine why
why Kathy was mad at her and then I
imagine Kyle was mad at Kathy for like
having to do nothing not lift a finger
and being the favorite on the show
speaking of sisters on round television
can we talk about with Housewives of uh
New Jersey yes so who because it it
truly looks I heard a rumor actually
what that um they have not started
filming and I want to be clear this is
not a rumor like from Margaret we know
we're friends this is not for Margaret I
heard about it like from production like
other production about their production
like friends of production that they've
they're on a like whatever indefinite
Hiatus
um because they can't figure out who the
cast is going to be which means to me
that it's true Melissa and Teresa are
like not gonna work with each other so
if that is the case who deserves to stay
okay well that's a good who deserves to
stay uh is Melissa like Melissa okay in
my mind I'm team Melissa I am too so in
my mind Melissa deserves to stay because
she didn't do anything wrong and she
shouldn't be kicked off because she has
gotten into an argument with a with a
deeply irrational illogical human being
yes so that's the ethical in my opinion
answer who will stay is Teresa because
it's you know she's the OG but do you
feel like eventually like there's been
so many OG's that have run their course
as well though and I'm starting to see
Bravo like when Bravo starts to give
people the edit that they deserve you
know Bravo's like we're [__] fat
they're like Teresa will not be fired
like I think the network has far too
much respect for what she's done for the
show for what she's put on the show for
the prison like I think that there's a
mutual respect between her and the
network which I do get right but it's
and that leaves me I do think Melissa
will be the one to be asked to leave if
someone gets asked to leave and I don't
think that's fair so maybe that's why
there's a Hiatus because they know that
that's the case and they want to keep
Melissa and Joe on I just feel like
they're like what would Teresa do if she
wasn't fighting with right and by the
way there's something to be said about a
lot of the value Melissa brings to the
show was her husband and her husband is
a lot of people's favorite character on
the show and he is the center of that
guy group yeah and he kind of created
that guy group I know and I don't know
if they would all hang out without him I
agree so she kind of she has a good leg
to stand on for for her staying in the
group I know it's just so crazy I will
say though and I am team Melissa and Joe
but damn if my
ex-s sister-in-law I was on a reality
show and she showed up like season two
or three I'd have a [__] conniption
and I mean when I was married to Osborne
yeah yeah for sure for sure
but she's also the most boring person on
the planet so she wouldn't like last
more than one season but unlike Melissa
Melissa didn't do anything wrong by
coming on the show like yeah it's that's
like a terrible feeling for Teresa this
is my thing and now you're coming on it
but like why can't it be both of your
things like it's really like sharing is
caring and
she she didn't do anything wrong by
coming on the show no and also like like
and even Andy was like if she wasn't
good she wouldn't have been on like it's
not just you like she's hot she has like
the lifestyle she has a great
personality great husband can you
imagine like Theresa must have been
screaming on the inside ego Twisted me
like I got this thing and like it's my
thing and then like somebody else comes
I would be vomiting dying but that
doesn't mean Melissa did anything wrong
that's true that's just what I think
nope it's true um so Kathy will be
sorely missed like I don't love this I
don't love it either maybe we can I
don't know get her back in I don't know
maybe like at a dinner party or
something I think by the way it's only
like a couple scenes with her I don't
know I mean I know she had like a
traumatic last season because like
people were saying really disparaging
things against her but for the most part
she doesn't have to do a whole lot and
everything she does people love I know
and like she there was like decent
evidence that she had this full blown
mental breakdown like nobody even cared
like people still love her so I didn't
really do whatever she wants oh whatever
she wants she's in I mean a dream this
next story is something I
probably would have rolled my eyes out
like a few years ago but now I was like
a woman who's actually getting older I'm
into it oh I'm ready Jennifer Aniston is
being praised for showing off her gray
hair people are saying it's refreshing
so Jennifer Aniston is earning Praise on
Instagram for embracing her natural
silver strands in a post announcing the
latest launch from her hair care brand
okay oh which is well this is really
smart yeah the 54 year old's new
intensive Hair Repair treatment is meant
to be used once a week who cares
um but she's basically just sharing this
video on how to use it she says sleep in
it you can use it for an hour or
whatever right and people notice she's
just at her house looking really cute
and fresh-faced and her hair is in like
a half up half down and her roots are
gray and that's something a lot of you
know women of a certain age in Hollywood
would touch up yeah I have to say the
gray is not my favorite like when I go
gray like I will be touching it up but
because she has like this really bright
blonde hair it actually looks really
pretty
um and I just kind of love this like
this is not something this is something
I would have been like oh who cares or
just been like dye your hair [__] but I
don't know I'm like actually a person
who like every now and then now like
finds gray hairs yeah the fact that like
somebody's so famous and so rich and
really that I feel like for so many
years was like the picture of beauty yes
to be embracing it like I actually not
to be so lame like I do find this
empowering well like not all heroes wear
capes yeah I mean it listen Diane
Keaton's been rocking that white hair
for [__] ever she's the OG and I love
it I will say though as a woman of a
certain age I have started to have Grays
I put in like money pieces because they
kind of cover it up but like then also
they like have a mind of their own
sometimes they're just like I'm blonde
today and other days they're like I'm
kind of orange and I'm like what is
happening what is your take on Grace
like what are you gonna do about yours
when they really come in everybody has
like Strays no matter how old you are I
have been trying to cover them and like
I feel like I'm gonna have to just go a
little bit lighter to cover them because
it's too hard to match my actual hair
color
um but I don't know I mean I wish I
could be a woman who could be like I
would love to be that cool to like go
gray white gray but then like it's the
in between for me yes of course it's the
getting there it's not the destination
it's the journey we have to have like
half black half gray hair from here I
don't know if I could do it I know
that's tough I know but maybe there's a
world in which you can just like commit
to the grain just go full and gray like
instead of blonde maybe you can dye your
hair gray and in the six months that
like you dye it the new hair growing in
contact I mean listen like I just feel
like I know we're gonna move on to the
Apple Store but like if we can do what
we're doing with technology why can't we
figure this out no that's the way I feel
like about everything the way we were
able to put a man on the moon but like
we can't come up with a pill that like
makes me not tired all the time right
that's not Adderall like you know right
like why are people always tired like
why hasn't like modern medicine figured
that out oh no no like how come they
haven't found a cure for cancer but they
could put a man on the moon number one
question of my life there's just so many
things like we have self-driving cars I
know we can't kill a little disease
themselves it's ridiculous it's a
conspiracy it is a conspiracy yeah I
know don't even get me started they
don't want us to get better they don't
they don't want us to get better no they
want us to be like these feeble like you
know scared humans and they'll take all
of our money yeah fix the problem 100
yeah all right are you ready for our
fifth and final story that kind of blew
the tech World Wide Open yesterday my
brain's exploding because Apple had
their like bi-annual like conference
where they all just like stand on stage
and do PowerPoint presentations and tell
you about all their new shits and a lot
of them were actually really kind of
revolutionary yep so the one that
everyone's talking about is Apple has
announced FaceTime voicemail which
basically you call someone on FaceTime
they don't pick up instead of it just
ending you can leave them a little video
voicemail oh no kidding yeah oh that's
cool I know I thought we were gonna talk
about the goggles we'll talk about
everything oh the FaceTime voicemail
because most people these days like I
don't call you called me yesterday like
regular I'd call not FaceTime it was so
you were pooping
oh I was pooping but like you could have
FaceTime me I don't care like it was so
weird nobody calls anymore like for like
actual socialization love a call but
that's the thing like FaceTime first of
all I [__] FaceTime what and I I make
an exception for you because I love you
so much but like I I just feel like I
don't wanna I just don't want to look at
my own face but I like that they make me
really small so I can focus on you and
not it's not small enough I'm still
looking at myself it's terrible but I
just and taste family's very face timing
it just feels like an assault in my like
I don't know personal space and privacy
oh my God I [__] love FaceTime but I
do love an oh like an old school call so
I don't know if I'm gonna actually love
this feature well there's another
feature that's that you're gonna love
it's called like voice you know back in
the day when you had an answering
machine yes you would screen a voicemail
yes so now when somebody calls you and
you want to know like what they want you
can listen live you I don't know if you
can listen but it'll transcribe it'll
come up and be like yeah hey Taylor this
is your doorman you know there's a
prostitute here for you you want me to
send them up and you can actually answer
as they're leaving the voicemail if you
end up wanting to talk to them oh so
it's basically like a modern answering
machine which is really cool I like that
yeah yeah
um
and then they also have these I don't
understand VR at all okay explain it to
me last night dinner okay so basically I
am scared about our society yeah with
all of these technological advancements
I just feel like we're just gonna go so
into our own selves and there's gonna be
like we already have trouble with
communication in this world like this is
gonna real I'm
every fiber of my soul is fighting this
but like I'm also like I will not be
left behind like I can't type because my
parents thought that the internet was a
portal to porn which was actually
accurate but like I'm also very behind
like I can't type did you never do like
in maybe you might have been older than
me no I we had computer classes maybe
speaking that like where you would write
the fox jumped over the thing I would
play Oregon Trail do you know what
vented Oregon Trail no I'm gonna blow
your mind and this is how he's so rich
who
Kevin O'Leary
I'm blanking Mr Wonderful from Shark
Tank oh my god oh he says he should like
in the intro when they tell you all
about the Sharks his is that he sold his
education company for three billion
dollars and part of his education
company was Oregon Trail favorite
[__] game ever bring it back my
honestly my theories out of it I'll
watch it I'm still recovering from my Ox
dying of dysentery
such a huge loss for me my kid got
typhoid it's terrible I like how they
would just like normalize like oh your
husband's dead oh okay I guess game over
I was talking to
um I don't want to give away their
identity but I was like by the way you
are so bad at that when you're on
podcasts and stuff you always think
you're being so subtle and you're not so
I just want you to like speak carefully
okay so I met these two people recently
who um were brought up Mormon okay and
and then that's all the details I'll
give but they were telling about like
their experience in the church and like
they're no longer in the church but they
haven't like fully defected like um
Allah Whitney yeah okay
um but they were saying that basically
like I I mean like you did you do um
Birthright I didn't I wasn't eligible at
the time but I know a million people who
did yeah he did and then there was like
like something I can't remember now um
like Curious dose or something with
catechism it doesn't [__] matter but
my thing is like it's like a like a
teenage Journey yeah in Mormonism it's
called like after you graduate high
school you get like a letter and you
have to go and that's what the Book of
Mormon is about oh proselytize it's
called um
can you call like it's kind of like a
rum Springer but the opposite yes it's
like the opposite it's like their
version of like Birthright I guess where
they go they can teach seminaries and
yeah so they'd go like Into the
Wilderness yeah and they like I mean
have like nothing modern whatsoever and
they put them in families and they have
to like role play the Oregon Trail
essentially was my understanding of it
okay psychotic oh that was the whole
story yeah yeah no that was such a waste
of time I'm so sorry that wasn't
bothering me what that word is called
our Mormon listeners
no it's like our Mormon listeners are
going to want to kill me but I've seen
videos of girls like who are really into
Mormonism like getting their letter from
the church because you're going to it's
kind of like college like you're going
to
Uganda like random places but it's like
they have to go camping and like
proselytize and be putting fake families
and then like they have to wear like
like outfit is it missionary
like you go on your mission you get your
mission I think it's different I think
that this is different that mission is
fun you like travel the world this is
like hell torture oh yeah did you ever
watch Breaking Amish yes such a good
show loves it I would love when they
would go on their rump spring and like
never come back from the English world I
know I would never come back from
Springer no me neither never this would
be nice about being honest you don't
like put on makeup or brush your hair
I'm here for that I'm I feel that I'm
part Amish yeah in my soul in the sense
that I don't like brushing my hair and I
also like half of half down so much
which makes me a polygamist half up half
down hair yeah is that how the Amish
wear their hair
yeah no they wear like a white cap fine
polygamous do polygamists do yes yes
they love a half up of down
um so goggles oh right yes I'm very
scared so they're really [__] cool
basically so like the technology is it
requires it's a lot of about eye
technology and then also voice and then
fingers but like when you want to like
touch an app because like it's basically
a screen that it's like everything is
here it's like you're only seeing your
phone it's if your phone was like right
right exactly but it you can actually
see through the lens so you're not like
in a blackout state so like when a
person comes into the room if you're
like in there watching it will like open
up a spot so you can actually see
somebody because they don't want it to
be super anti-social yeah exactly so
it's a good way to get attacked like if
you're just in your goggles because you
would see breaking into your house you
would see right there got it it would
open up for them but like you like if
you want to tap on an app like you do
like this with your fingers like how oh
and wow I guess basically like if you
put them on and like you want to watch
tick tocks you're just like in the tick
tock yes kind of then it was also like
you can also like watch TV but you don't
have to be in your home you could be in
a landscape and it's like why no why I
feel like they've been trying to make
virtual reality goggles a thing for so
long yes I'm not I'm not into it I will
say so they're gonna be 3 500 I know my
wife wants them I'm not [__] buying
them oh my God I was no one use it
though I know you would okay absolutely
you come over use it and [__] pee on
our couch I'll pee on it I'll be having
such a good time I won't even realize
that I had to pee and next thing I know
couch is yellow how does that sound
I don't know I just I feel like they are
they're making me nervous but I will not
be left behind again I know I need to
learn how to do this for the future yeah
like all the hand motions that are yes a
part of it exactly I'm gonna walk into
your apartment you're just gonna be like
doing interpretive dancing I'm like what
are you doing Taylor you're like I'm
practicing for my VR goggles arrive
when do you think you're gonna get them
because we're almost at them at some
point no I actually don't think so I
feel like it's one of the things that
like Tech has tried to push on us for so
many years anyway it's a novelty thing
it's cool to have I don't think it'll
become like a standard part I don't
think it's become ubiquitous but imagine
like not having to bring your iPad and
your headphones with you on a plane and
just being able to put your goggles on
that's where they got me yeah no that's
pretty sick you can like [__] what
like can you imagine
I feel like it kind of reminds me of the
Apple watch it's a v it's very simple
apple watch is cool it has a lot of
benefits but it never became like a
thing that everybody needed yeah it's
fetch it's like never really happened
it's a novelty yes and I feel like
that's what this is gonna be I hope
you're right because I don't want to
live in this world no you know yeah and
I don't want like my family in this
world like it's bad enough I feel like
people sit around with their kids and
everyone's on their own iPads like
imagine if you're like this scary it
really is I absolutely just love you
like more than anything thank you so
much for being here I really enjoyed
this episode this was I think what some
of our best work really I felt like so
brain dead today like I couldn't get a
sentence out oh my God I thought we were
so funny like the whole Pride
conversation amazing
fantastic so make sure to follow Taylor
if you don't already if you liked what
you heard here Taylor also does a daily
show it's on patreon it's extremely
cheap I keep telling her to raise her
price she does an hour-long show every
single weekday for 6.95 like that's
cheap at the price she's a great co-host
she's hysterical she also has a free
podcast once a week called Taste of
Taylor but if you want to sign for
patreon it's patreon.com
thetaylorstracker show thank you follow
her on Instagram God the Lord knows she
needs it at Taylor strecker yes and
that's it thank you so much for
listening to the toast the millennial
Morning Show where we deliver the fast
five stories that you need to know every
Monday through Friday on YouTube so if
you're watching this on YouTube please
feel free to subscribe and give this
video a thumbs up we're also available
as a podcast anyway podcast
box all the places
we are hope you guys have an amazing day
tomorrow we are in studio again so there
will be video and Joey camasta is
joining me bye